that's nice watch this take some one way
in the drop step look at how much room
and territory he covers
joelle probably wanted to make that so
he can get a traditional three-point
play picks up the foul
nonetheless his efficiency at the strike
kept the sixers in that one in philly
back in november joel 16 of 21 that
night
finished with 42 points 14 rebounds and
again
his first game back after a really
difficult battle with cohen
splits the free throw the foul on that
penetration from the bible
a little too cute from russell embiid
the steal
joelle coast
[Music]
beverly
picking up the foul tried to take the
charge
was there early
but joelle at the last second watch this
tries to avoid him and as he does
beverly slides his feet that takes him
out of good defensive position hence the
block
[Applause]
hey sixers fans xfinity mobile connects
you to america's most reliable 5g
network break free from the big three
and save hundreds a year with xfinity
mobile
rivers conversation continuing
patrick beverly coming over to have a
word with malloy as well
edward's guardian harding james harden
driving and finishing
and so it begins the hardened arrow with
the sixers
that stutter step dribble
watch this watch the little cross over
here as he gets
right past edwards
right to the basket strong enough to
pick
fight through that contact get to the
bucket with the finish
[Applause]
martin completes the three-point play
spider-man like joelle
contact a late whistle
from acosta who was behind the play and
beverly not happy
i don't blame him i don't normally
agree with patrick beverly on anything
but he's got a point there there's the
steal by maxie great individual play
sixers change ends and it seems as if
the referee waited to see what happened
with the ball
that is not how
that call is supposed to go down we'll
take it nonetheless
second personal on beverly fourth team
foul already in this first quarter as we
take a look at our taco bell tank most
40 and 10 games
since the 2017-18 season look at the two
guys at the top of that list
well
it's nice to have two guys that are
still
you know functioning at their relative
probably leading to minnesota buckets
joelle splitting the defense and growing
another foul
he's already been to the free throw line
three times tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
three game flex packs are now here
because we only have 24 games left so
short perfect gift for you
perfect gift for friends create your own
three game package with the games you
want to see plus you'll receive enhanced
priority to playoff seats for more info
sixers.com flex tickets at 76ers.com or
you can call 215 339-7676
it used to be closer to the middle of
the season the all-star breakup remember
folks we started early this year
started a little deeper into october
than we normally do and hence
the reason why we're further along in
the season when the all-star break comes
every player thinks they can count every
shot
[Music]
again frustrating setting in for him
because as long as hardin's got his
dribble alive he treats defenders like
dorana yo-yo back and forth
constantly trying to keep them off
balance that's when their most
vulnerable kicks
the focus of tonight's indeed
player resume
second right now in the nba an assist
per game to go along with the 22 and a
half and eight rebounds that he brings
to the table
i know i'd like to see that field goal
percentage go up a little bit
folks have been pointing out that he's
not averaging as many points on that
note allah as he
not just from the field but his coach
says also from the line
hardened four wolves around him
joel embiid
making his way along the score is stable
to check back in
here's that last play give you a
baseline view of it splits three
defenders
[Applause]
and you can see the reach
by prince with that left hand on the
drive
no-brainer for the officials
that's gonna be number two on prince
[Applause]
that was one of the things that uh
chris finch
wolf's coach pointed out pre-game as
well yeah joel embiid gets to the line a
lot
so does james hard
[Applause]
both guys
supplementing their scoring by
activity at the line
[Applause]
out mv back in
ten points six rebounds already tonight
for joel
harden splits the free throws into maxie
back to joel repost turns
and draws the foul on reed
[Applause]
[Music]
as the new and only official ticketing
partner of the philadelphia 76ers
ticketmaster has the widest selection of
seats so you never miss a game at
ticketmaster.com 76ers to buy or sell
your tickets today
and uh
allah have heard that the the get in
price for our next home game which will
be
james harden's home debut this coming
wednesday against the new york knicks
uh it's increased 250 percent
since since everyone kind of figured out
that he was going to be making his
overall debut here tonight and then the
home debut expected on wednesday so at
last check
around 66
wow 49 is what the timberwolves were
shooting
joelle count it and it'll head to the
line
[Applause]
[Music]
here's that play again
harden with the basketball they switch
the rotation late in the form of russell
he reaches i don't know what he's
complaining about it's an obvious reach
[Applause]
on russell
9-10 from the line
so far tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
seemed late but we will take it
[Applause]
end-to-end basketball
coming at you nice tap from matisse
hardin
garners it and he's off and running
picks up the contact along the way you
see the bench getting into it as well
the foul called
james at the line
[Applause]
pretty good looking sixers debut for
james harden so far
you mentioned though heads you play from
that guy dipped that one out too hard
well knew he couldn't get it himself so
what'd he do
saw harden
heading in the right direction
heading into the front court tapped it
to him
james hits them both
from that
happened so far sixers up ten hardened
step back and the foul
[Applause]
the first of many
in red white and blue
poor vanderbilt
really with very little option left the
little pitter pat
the step back
and vanderbilt
just trying to get a hand up
off balance picks up the contact
got to give harden room to land
vanderbilt
fringing fringing upon that room
43rd time that the timberwolves have
seen james harden in his career i just
think right now he's trying to stay in
this matchup with joelle embiid one on
one
joelle fouled again
not realizing it doesn't really matter
joelle's already won the matchup you're
down 23 if you're carl anthony towns
matchup's over
and joelle with 23 of the sixers 84
points so far tonight
catching his breath
sixers fans bring your group to a game
and enjoy the excitement of 76ers
basketball all you need is a group of 10
to qualify i don't think that will be
hard to find at this point of the season
tickets
that's just
24.00.com tickets or you can call
215.339.7676
i mentioned back home
against the
struggling new york knicks after that
great season they had last year
complete 180 this season
looks like if you ask me tom thibodeau's
reign there in new york has perhaps come
to an end
get the shot they want
step back
four-point opportunity
for james harden
so much for easing your way into things
philly
here i am
take a look at that step back over the
much taller
carl anthony towns he got a four
four-point play down one end of the
floor james
looking for the return
and you heard him say even though he's
obviously only been in philly for a
couple of days and
he feels like home five is great and